you know when i was a kid every summer
my father would take me and my brother
to cooperstown to go to the baseball
hall of fame so recently it was a big
thrill to get to meet some of these hall
of famers who it turns out are real
people
they're actual
they're human men that play the sport so
i got to meet them and we filmed it so
why don't you watch it while i listen
this is aussie the smooth smith yeah can
we make a new nickname for you go ahead
the smooth this move
come on
so i am not a sports fan
what is a good way for a non-sports fan
to enjoy a baseball game drink a lot of
beer drink a lot of beer blackouts
that's it who cares who's up ball down
fall down trying to pick up a girl yeah
i believe miss america's here have you
got it have you laid your papers on i
haven't seen her yet sorry i'm nervous
why are you nervous pretty well i know a
little bit about you because i did some
research okay the thing that makes me
most excited is that you were on the
simpsons that's right you are a 15-time
all-star
what's cooler that or being on the
simpsons well i have to say that it's uh
it's cooler being on the simpsons
you have board game night at your house
don't you i bet you make them sweet hot
chocolate wednesday wednesday nights
yeah you say that in jess but i'm going
to be there with sorry under my arm okay
well you're
welcome i want to go to your log cabin
and make hooch
are we on the couch now yeah we can do
that if we want how's your mind on the
couch what's your relationship like with
your mother has anyone ever told you you
look like soda popinski no who's that
you sort of what the heck is
that
he's a video game boxer oh i have no
clue man i have inadequacy issues that
never never fully you know was able to
to get out right always another at-bat
you're right always another no it's
never good enough for her
i just want to be loved man my brother
and my father are the hugest fans of
baseball they're going to be so mad that
i'm talking to you right now well tell
them i said hi i will
we can call them from your house while
we're playing yes we got scrabble
i love to play uh uno you're you're a
big uno guy um dry formula yes i'm the
best in the business really oh yeah
audrey
god i want to play uno with ozzie smith